which brings me to the next hilarious
bit in the whole narrative
what's this the new york times now
acknowledging that maybe people don't
like violent riots hmm here's the funny
part
i tell you what man they wrote the new
york times wrote this abolish the police
those who survived the chaos in seattle
aren't so sure
what is it like when a city abandons a
neighborhood
and the police vanish business owners
describe a harrowing experience
of calling for help and being left all
alone you know what's funny about it
they mentioned they mentioned
specifically that the the the main guy
in their story is a gay man of middle
eastern descent
who moved from texas there so he could
be more comfortably out
and the reason that's funny is not
because of this person it's because they
ignored his plight
when the chaz was going on in seattle
and auntie was you know a romping about
with guns
oppressing this man harassing him
harassing his customers
and and barricading him in some
instances from even coming in to where
he where his
store was the new york times wrote a
whole bunch of articles that were just
like
they were dumb things like why is
everybody talking about auntie
it's a summer of love we're gonna have a
great time
business owners love jazz
really do they go ahead
this guy look at this young white men
wielding guns would harang customers
as well as mr khan a gay man of middle
eastern descent who moved from texas so
he could be more comfortably out
to get into his coffee shop he sometimes
had to seek the permission of
self-appointed armed guards to cross a
border they directed
they barricaded us all in here mr khan
said and they were sitting in lawn
chairs with guns
for 23 days in june about six blocks in
the
city's capitol hill neighborhood were
claimed by left-wing demonstrators and
declared police free
protesters held it as liberation from
police oppression from white supremacy
and a catalyst for a national movement
and they go and talk about you know
george floyd how it started
they say some even call for abolishing
the police altogether
and closing down precincts which
happened in seattle that has left small
business owners as lonely voices in
progressive areas arguing that police
officers are necessary
and that cities cannot function without
a robust public safety presence
yeah well here we go they mentioned
portland oregon
many other businesses yeah yeah in in
in interviews they expressed support for
the black lives matter movement
but they also were their businesses
already debilitated by the coronavirus
pandemic will struggle to survive
if police departments and city
governments cannot protect them you know
what
i i'm sorry man i don't really care
anymore to be honest you know why
because of what they didn't stand up for
themselves when they were there because
these cities vote for them
and and look at a certain point i can be
like i am sorry this is happening to you
but after months of this with the
democratic states locking down and
destroying the local economies
conservatives republican states didn't
didn't do this as much they didn't
they're doing it in some places with the
democrats and
some republicans um you know overseeing
the arrest of business owners
at a certain point you've got to leave
because you are being targeted
because the government is oppressive or
you can't vote for these people
but i'll tell you what right now there's
a tendency i see these journalists post
on twitter some of them
these are these are people who actually
like quit the news industry will point
out like
has anybody checked the numbers on these
you know conservative republican states
they didn't lock down
and they're doing fine and you look at
new york that went nuts and is the worst
in the country
yeah or was and then you got de blasio
and cuomo out there
touting that they're the best they
handled it the best since day one
while they literally laugh as they burn
everything
to the ground yeah i covered a story
earlier on my site on one of my channels
where they've put homeless people in
upper west side luxury hotels
yeah three of them and do you know what
these people are doing yeah they're
pissing in the hallways they're
doing drugs everywhere offering crack to
you know
the the woman the mother who's walking
their two-year-old kid down i'm gonna
give you that's crazy i'm gonna give you
guys a family-friendly warning earmuffs
if you've got kids all right i'm gonna
i'm gonna say it one more time if you
got kids listening
earmuffs because here we go
there's a photo of a dude cranking it
on the sidewalk outside this hotel yup
that's what new york city has become oof
how how crazy man
and the daily mail going back in time
yeah they really want to bring it all
back to the way things used to be
maybe i can can you think of any reason
why de blasio's doing this
to maybe to de-gentrify
new york
i i'm kind of i'll tell you what though
i mean if you think about it if all the
wealthy people are leaving all the
property value is going to die
out and then it's an opportunity for
people to snatch it all up yeah
so these billionaires will buy up all
these garbage properties uh
yeah and i didn't even think about it
that way but i guess if you think about
the long run
all the people with money are like you
know what i'll just buy it and while
it's
in terrible shape whatever i don't care
eventually it'll get back you know bill
de blasio is a landlord
of course he is yeah he makes like nine
grand a month according to one article i
was reading from rental income
so here's what happens they burn new
york city to the ground
they buy it up they buy it up they as in
the establishment politicians their
buddies
so new york becomes uninhabitable for a
couple of years yeah
relatively wow property values collapse
to a substantial degree
wealthy real estate developers come in
and buy up as much as they can from all
the small businesses
and look one of the issues i have with
the progressive tax system right now
is that it stops at i think 250k
which means if you make you know 300
you're being taxed very heavily above
250 okay which makes it harder for you
to become
a wealthy industrialist or real estate
agent you know uh
tycoon or whatever i see but if you're
making millions upon millions of dollars
you're being taxed at the same
percentage it's easy for you with your
millions to make big investments
so this is one one of the things i
really do agree with bernie sanders on
is expanding the progressive tax
brackets in fact
oh that makes sense yeah so yeah so
bernie's proposal
actually would lower taxes for people
who make i think like 250 to
to 500 you'd pay less because not
everybody
who makes 250 you know not everybody who
makes more than 250 is making
50 billion so it would just basically
you know expand
it would it would number stretch it out
yeah and i think that makes sense
yeah it definitely makes sense and then
what ends so but anyway that's a whole
other issue the point is
there are people in new york city who
are wealthy
maybe they make five hundred thousand
dollars a year these are the one percent
in new york
but you make 500 000 a year you might
own one or two buildings in new york
city
you're someone like bezos who's got you
know liquid assets
in the in the in hundreds of billions
you know 100 something billion
and he owns a bunch of hard assets bezos
can you know elon musk billionaires can
start buying up more properties with
less risk
so here's what happens when bill de
blasio just
decimates these cities then the people
who are making
half a mill have to sell their one or
two properties
maybe they have a little bit more than
that i mean i think a lot of people
making half a mil probably are real
estate developers probably own rental
properties but now it's now they've got
no rent no renties
no rent coming in so they sell at a
massive discount in desperation
and they get out of the city then the
big the big wigs
the real the real money they can come in
and snap their fingers
tell they tell their their real estate
you know their management company they
say hey
buy up that whole row of buildings
they're just they're up for sale i'll
take them all for dirt
and then we'll sit on them for a couple
of years i got nothing to worry about
and now
you know five years from now or whatever
when the city's recovered it will have a
lot
less individual ownership of these
properties
so maybe that's why they're burning it
all down anyway the main point however
is is more so what the far left has been
doing
with the rioting and that's another
point
why would bill de blasio allow these
people to go out and riot
why would he paint these messages on the
ground this resulted in driving away
half a million people
and some of the wealthier people who
live there it's going to make the
property values of new york
go in the gutter i'll keep my eye on it
i'm going to buy a building in a few
years yeah well no joke i'm not going
anywhere near new york ever again
yeah that's a good point because think
about look unless you're going to be one
of these ultra wealthy
you know billionaires or millionaires
yeah you're going to be
smackdown yeah it reminds me of that
story from donald trump where he was
like walking with one of his kids
and he pointed the homeless guy and says
see that man he's wealthier than i am
because donald because trump's
liabilities were higher than his his
assets or whatever yeah he owed more
than he actually had but he was still a
billionaire it's like a weird
weird how that works right and it
reminds me of that
they're going to be a lot of people who
will buy up a bunch of properties even
if they're not super wealthy once the
once they go down to the gutter
and then they'll figure out ways to
maintain it just enough so that when the
property value goes up
they'll turn a quick profit all in all
though
i think ultimately the city is just
going to be burnt to the ground you know
figuratively
i agree you know so i i would i would i
would stay away with them stay away from
them well i mean there's also the the
conspired
uh the conspiracy that we may go to war
and that they're trying to keep everyone
from the big cities well that's what
somebody said in the chat the other day
oh yeah on the super chat
that what if they're trying to push
people out of cities out of fear of some
kind of strike
yeah yeah maybe i guess i think maybe is
always the easiest way to look at it
because yeah i mean
you know we're we're dangerously close
to war with china trump's actions are
really going to
rough ruffle some feathers man true yeah
so it's possible
and what what's like i said it before
man you think about the results of a lot
of this and it is beneficial to the
united states in the event of a war
not not the not the civil unrest and
discord that's bad for us this is
this unity but if you've got people
leaving cities decentralizing the
our economy going you know us only
essential jobs now so people are getting
away from vanity jobs
trying to find jobs that actually are
essential to help the country function
they're buying guns like crazy yeah
record yeah record numbers so
you know if we did go to war well i'm
gonna have a ton of guns everywhere a
lot of armed people
and i'll tell you what trained i mean
they're they're not only by i mean i'm
reading stories about it everyone's
buying guns but everyone's training
they're talking about how you know they
were scared to have a gun they
didn't believe in guns at the beginning
of the year for most of their life
but now they've got a gun and they've
gotten training which is very important
and now they're like you know i i feel
like i can handle myself in situations
where a gun is required and it's like
good because you should you should know
what you're doing with it i tweeted this
out i think it was early today
seven about seven months ago i said
straight up
i do not want any guns in my house
period just no
just not happening i'm not gonna deal
with this then covet happened
and i was like wow people are rushing to
buy guns they're worried about this i
should consider this
yeah and the riots happen and i was like
one gun please and i went to the store
and
now i have several and crowder actually
got me a sig but
we're we're being we're trying to we're
trying to expand and move to a bigger
facility so we're a bit we're a bit
jammed up in that regard but yes
crowder did send me that sig and it's
chilling waiting for me modified all
ready to go i just can't go and pick it
up
it's got to be shipped to a new location
workaholic
it's not it's not just that it's got to
be shipped to the proper location that's
right
to put it simply exactly you know and
right now it had to be modified so it
had to be sent to a specific facility
now that it is it's got to be sent to
another place but we're like a week out
or two weeks from relocating so i'm like
if they're gonna say
yeah it's too it's too it's it's a weird
yeah we're jammed up
but i'll tell you what man i was
thinking about it
and i was you know so we had the the was
it the the ag in new york
yeah tries is trying to dissolve the nra
oh yeah i don't know anything about the
nra to be honest
other than like they're like a really
really old like i guess they call
themselves the oldest civil rights
organization
because it was formed in like 1870
something oh wow yeah so i don't know
uh much about them they're accused of a
bunch of wrongdoing and stuff but it's
interesting to me now that i'm paying
attention to this because i'm like
when i see these democrats now say
things like we should have a nationwide
gun ban on certain things i'm now now i
see myself going like no
yeah no how dare you seven months ago
nope
it was the riots that did it and i
started i sat and thought about it
really and i was like oh wow my opinion
really did change on this
because the threat became you know too
big
and i think that that really is a good
way to understand people's political
opinions on certain issues
the people who are pro-2a many of them
live out in the middle of nowhere and
must defend themselves
they don't have this this luxury of a
cop who's around the corner
and even when the cop is around the
corner there's no guarantee they'll be
there fast enough if someone breaks in
your house well now we got these
these places that who where you're
talking about where they were
around the corner key word there were
they they're no longer there
they're defunding them right so they're
making these cities
that used to have this presence of
police
around the corner that you can be like
you know what they're around the corner
they'll be here in no time
you know we don't need guns in the
cities this goes back to
the whole democrats the riots have have
have ruined them in my opinion
yeah i agree because now i'm thinking
about it and if they control the riots
i probably would still be complacent and
comfortable not thinking twice about
needing
self-defense that's a good point but
because they supported black lives
matter and they supported the riding and
they still do
yeah and they still i mean they're
shutting down
going to church pretty much anything
other than rioting
they they're cracking down on now now
i'm more like
i can't i i men i can't support any
anybody who comes out for gun control in
any capacity
literally literally any and it's because
of the riots and because they've they've
demoralized the police they've stripped
them of their access and resources
and they're viola they openly violate
the law to benefit themselves
absolutely every all the time non-stop
it's getting
more and more blatant too so now i'm
sitting here thinking like these people
these people hate me they oppose me and
i have done nothing to them and it's the
weirdest thing
to see like bill de blasio all the
horrifying things this man has done yeah
like man i tell you he really hates
people he just hates
hey it's right there he bypasses the
permit process
using taxpayer funds to paint a
political message that will benefit his
campaign
and then has the nypd guarding that
message 27 officers
more than any unit that's even in the
nypd
so not only are they defunding the
police taking these
the crime units out of these areas that
need them
that now i i don't remember the exact
number over 180 percent increase in
homicides now
happening in these areas but he's got 27
officers
guarding this black lives matter and
they're they're actually there was an
article i read today about they're
thinking about
just not repainting it because it's been
vandalized so much yeah
it's causing taxpayers more money now
well i mean
just money period and it's too much if
uh
if if it were up to me and i was going
to be filing action i'll i'll just put
it this way
my my personal thoughts on this is that
bill de blasio
should immediately be impeached
for taking taxpayer funds and all 27 of
those officers should be fired and be
stripped of their retirements or
whatever they have coming to them
they should immediately lose their jobs
done end of story lose their jobs and
any benefit they should have had
kicked out stripped nothing i'll tell
you why you aid in a bet
a corrupt politician who is illegally
placing
a a campaign message and stand guard
over it that's your choice
and if you want to stand against the
people and against the constitution
i will absolutely be standing against
you so how about this
we get some legal action against bill de
blasio for violating the law and
stealing
taxpayer funds to repeatedly defend a
political message for his campaign
and all of the cops who thought i'm just
gonna i'm just gonna do whatever i'm
told and support this corrupt politician
stealing taxpayer funds you're along
with them
i'll tell you what man if you're
standing next to the criminal
and you're blocking us from from from
dealing with it
you're aiding and abetting just like i
said with antifa and the wall of moms
you want to be a wall of moms standing
in front of these far left extremists on
explosives
you may as well be you're you're aiding
you're literally
contributing to that that's another gang
i what moms
they're all dressing together they're
all dressed in the same they're all
attacking
the the precincts they're they're
they're just as guilty
as the other rioters they're they're
they are the other writers the same
thing
you're absolutely they just changed
their clothes but they're a legitimate
gang they've got a
group they've got a name they've got an
outfit they're attacking just the same
that's a gang yeah i never name it i'm
just i'm on the wall of mine
at home because i want people to realize
that so listen
i am i am absolutely fed up when i read
these articles
that are so tribalist they will defend
the police who are violating the law
and i'm like nah i'm not playing that
game yeah my my
my views my my defense is for the
constitution of this of these united
states of this country
of upholding the law so i'm no fan of
the cops who killed brianna taylor i'm
no fan of police brutality but i'll tell
you this
there is no excuse for defending someone
like bill de blasio
there is no excuse for seizing the legal
firearm of someone defending their
property from a violent mob that they're
scared of because these people have been
implicated in murdering others
so when i see these videos man of the of
the cops
like there was a copper resting um
what's beveling was that her name yeah
bevel and beatty as she's yelling for
funding the police
i'm like yeah you know what man there
are a lot of really really good cops in
this country especially the local guys
here that i talk to these guys are
awesome
yeah they are and there are a lot of
cops that straight up said we will not
enforce unconstitutional law
remember that one cop who did that viral
video and he got fired for it really you
got fired for that
oh and out in seattle or something right
he was talking out about it yeah and he
was like i will not be enforcing
unconstitutional laws and all that stuff
and then they terminate him yeah these
guys are heroes i agree
but the people who are like i don't care
about you i don't care about the
constitution if
if bill de blasio wants to siphon public
funds for his re-election campaign i'll
stand right next to him and protect him
like that that to me is is someone
pissing on the constitution
truth i'm not happy about it or how
about uh what's the
mayor garcetti says his name in l.a with
draconian measures like what does he
do it's this it's these cities men yeah
exactly they find
people who are well who will willfully
say i don't care about the constitution
yep
but you it's it's amazing you go to
these suburbs and you go to smaller
towns
and you start to find more cops that are
like nah i don't play that game
the constitution is what we're here to
defend you know definitely yeah
but we even have it out here in the
philly suburbs the guys who arrested the
business owners
and i'm i'm you know what man maybe
maybe it's the uh it's it's that's so
weird
when i hear the lefties call people
bootlickers it's it's usually for the
stupidest nonsensical reason
that's like just not true but it reminds
me of when the left
actually like when i was the left left
me is the
easiest way to put it yeah i remember
when i was standing next to people who
were like what was bad
and i was like yes it is and now trump
is like war is bad and i'm like
thank you sir and i look to my left and
they're like no no we're we're you know
he said it so we're out
yeah so you never really thought where
was bad did you well it's interesting
because the whole walk away movement
why we didn't really go anywhere right
you were saying
the left walked away they're the ones
who kept veering further and further
away now we can't even see them
then they're over by my hand you can't
see that anymore they're over there
they're so far left they're off the
cliff they're falling to the ocean i
don't know what's going on yeah i'm
still i'm still in the middle i'm still
very much
right in the center where i've always
been you know look this
i see these articles right there was an
article about
adolescent where the two gym owners were
were there they're being basically
harassed by cops in the government and
the democratic mayor
and they eventually got arrested came
back kicked the door in that was awesome
you saw that video
when they kicked it in yeah yeah yeah
and there's some great america
oh yeah but there there were people
there saying
recognize the cops are just doing what
they they're being forced to do this and
all this stuff and i'm like no they
aren't could you imagine if everyone in
this country
who who you know stood up for themselves
stood up at the same time
all of this would be over and we
everything would be back to being great
you know back back to you know like the
the the the wonderful and glorious
economy under trump
which was the best in generations the
the best numbers of our lives jim cramer
says record low unemployment people's
salaries were skyrocketing that's where
we want to go to get there we need
everybody of good conscience to stand up
and say we've had enough of these
these you know ridiculous people burning
things down we've had enough of these
corrupt politicians stealing taxpayer
funds
and and we and we don't we don't get it
well the problem is is uh
it's ignorance people are too busy being
complaints
in their lives that are rather
comfortable compared to
other places in the world compared to
the past history of humanity like
what we've got right now people people
have a lot on their minds that isn't
politics that isn't
you know these things that if we all
knew
what was really going on it would be
really easy for everyone to go you know
what
we're all sick of this right yeah all
right let's get up and go
go march organizing what no one no one's
that like aware like you and i
we're in it we see it we every day we're
witnessing and
and analyzing everything breaking it
down
and not everyone has that time even
to even do a little bit of this kind of
stuff
remember when the police union in new
york came out and was just like
tearing into this defund the police
stuff yeah you know three
he said something one the one of the
union i think was the union president
said 375 million interactions with cops
overwhelmingly positive yeah he's
absolutely correct yeah
my question then is why are they
allowing bill de blasio to manipulate
them this way for his political
ambitions
that it's like that's you so this is
this is the big issue right i was
talking a friend of mine
about all the black lives matter stuff
and she said
where are the uh conservative
organizations going out protesting
creating petitions petitioning their
local politicians
and i was like that's a good question
and where are the moderates too
you know it's not it's not just about
conservatives but i'll tell you this the
moderates in my opinion i have the most
disdain for
people like me who have similar opinions
to mine because conservatives have been
actively out fighting
creating media posting messages having
church events having blue lives matter
rallies
and the disaffected liberal types are
few and far between and most won't say
anything and i'll tell you what i've
talked to a lot of them
and they're they're very scared i think
it's because they're still
lefty but they know they will be
destroyed by the left so right now what
do you get
you get a middle that should be the
loudest
but won't say anything and the
conservatives are picking up the slack
for the scared liberals who won't stand
up to the far left you see that letter
from harpers
where all these liberals came out and
they were like cancelled culture is bad
yeah and they got attacked where were
you when every single conservative was
coming out and saying
censorship is bad cancel culture is bad
they were saying well if i just keep my
mouth shut i'll be safe
and then it was too late they expect
everyone on the right to protect them
for
protect their rights meanwhile the far
left is taking over more and more of the
democratic party gaining more ground and
just tearing everything apart
and attacking and canceling these people
finally
we get like jk rowling to stand up these
are the people who should have stood up
a long time ago but they've been bending
the knee for so long they've emboldened
and empowered the far left
and that's something that trump
supporters say all the time that
the far left was only possible because
liberals and
empowered them and refused to stand up
stand up against them thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8 pm if
you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or check us out on
itunes and spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you